Додаткові поверхи,
розбудовані балкони
та перебудова в історичних будівлях.
Те, що для України є здебільшого звичним явищем, для Німеччини - нонсенс.
Як у ФРН регулюють надбудови й добудови, що можна змінювати вдома, а що - ні?
"Це моє житло, і я можу робити все, що хочу" -
принцип, звичний для деяких українців, у Німеччині не працює.
Власність на будинок зовсім не означає необмежену свободу дизайну.
Schwarzbau, тобто будівництво без дозволу, у Німеччині заборонене і суворо карається.
Перш ніж німецький власник зможе змінити щось у своїй оселі,
збільшити балкон, перефарбувати фасад будівлі чи замінити вікна,
необхідно спершу отримати дозволи від місцевих чиновників та сусідів.
Якщо проект не порушує планування забудови або будівельні норми,
з отриманням дозвільних документів складнощів не буде.
Щоправда, доведеться почекати від кількох тижнів до кількох місяців і сплатити значну суму -
заява від архітектора та дозвіл обійдуться щонайменше в тисячу євро
А ось якщо будівля перевищує максимально допустимі розміри у кілька разів,
або якщо внаслідок перебудови, приміром,
не дотримуються мінімальні відстані до власності сусідів,
у схваленні проекту, швидше за все, відмовлять
Якщо ж власник вже щось прибудував чи перепланував у своїй оселі,
але при цьому не порушив будівельні норми і відповідає усім стандартам,
зміни можуть схвалити, але це потребує додаткового розгляду.
Попри наявність чітких правил та рекомендацій, випадки незаконних перебудов у Німеччині все ж є.
Щоб їх виявити, використовують онлайн-сервіси на кшталт Google Street View та Google Maps,
можуть також робити аерознімки.
Про порушення нерідко повідомляють і сусіди.
Спокуса додати кілька квадратних метрів може дорого коштувати власникам житла.
Адже за несанкціоновані будівельні роботи передбачені штрафи.
У різних федеральних землях сума покарання різна: від 50 євро до 50 тисяч євро.
Крім того, власника можуть зобов’язати знести свої незаконні будівельні фантазії -
причому власним коштом.
І трапляється таке доволі часто.
Одна з останніх таких історій сталася у містечку Герфорд у землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія.
Після ремонту у багатоквартирному будинку на останньому поверсі на горищі
раптом з’явився балкон.
Оскільки дозволу на його зведення не було, міська влада постановила - балкон слід знести.
Власникам будинку це коштувало 10 тисяч євро.
Особлива стаття - перебудови і ремонт в історичних будівлях.
Для власників таких осель діють особливо суворі вимоги.
Увипадку з історичними будівлями усе залежить від того, яка саме їхня частина перебуває під охороною.
Якщо, приміром, захищено лише фасад,
усі дії зі зміни зовнішнього вигляду треба схвалити заздалегідь.
Причому для цього потрібен не лише дозвіл на будівництво,
але і схвалення компетентного відомства з охорони пам’ятників.
Втім, навіть фахверки, якщо вони збудовані незаконно, теж можуть знести.
Кілька років тому країну сколихнув випадок,
коли пенсіонерку зобов’язали прибрати фахверковий будинок,
який було зведено 75 років тому - без дозволу.
І це попри те, що будинок обійшовся їй у 250 тисяч євро, плюс видатки на ремонт.